programming throwdown episode 53 open source communities take it away jason hey everybody so today uh we have a really cool interview. We have Michael Rogers from the Node.js Foundation. And Michael, why don't you start by introducing yourself? Hey, I'm Michael Rogers. I do Node stuff. That's me. So what's your role in the foundation?
Programming Throwdown 第53期：开源社区，Jason，请开始你的表演。嘿，大家好，今天我们有一场非常棒的访谈。我们请到了来自 Node.js 基金会的 Michael Rogers。Michael，不如你先做个自我介绍？嘿，我是 Michael Rogers。我做 Node 相关的工作。这就是我。那么你在基金会担任什么角色呢？
So my role is, my title is Community manager, but I do quite a bit. So part of it is community work still and working with, we have a new governance structure and a TSC and a really big flourishing project that I'm sure that I'll get more into in a little bit. So I work with that on the community side and just kind of try to make sure that any roadblocks are pushed out of the way and that, you know, people are being connected when they need to get connected. And then I also actually do a lot of the internal foundation stuff. So we have a lot of resources from the Linux Foundation around marketing and PR and events that we use. So coordinating a lot of that, putting together, you know, board meetings and working with the board of directors and all that kind of stuff too.
我的角色是社区经理，但我做的事情相当多。其中一部分仍然是社区工作，我们有新的治理结构、技术指导委员会（TSC）以及一个非常繁荣的项目，我相信稍后我会详细介绍。所以我负责社区方面的工作，尽量确保扫清任何障碍，并确保人们在需要联系时能够建立联系。此外，我还负责很多基金会的内部事务。我们从 Linux 基金会获得了许多关于市场营销、公关和活动的资源，我负责协调这些工作，组织董事会会议，并与董事会成员合作等等。
Cool, cool. That sounds almost like a real company. I say that sarcastically. Well, it's yes and no. I mean, I think at a real company, you might have a boss. And everybody's my boss, it turns out. The board of directors are my boss.
酷，酷。听起来简直像一家真正的公司。我是讽刺地说。嗯，既是也不是。我的意思是，我认为在一家真正的公司里，你可能会有一个老板。但事实证明，每个人都是我的老板。董事会成员是我的老板。
The whole community is my boss, and then I also have a boss at the Linux Foundation. So yeah. Cool. I mean, that's the hierarchy, right? Everyone's each other's boss. Right, right. That's one way to look at it. So what is sort of the mission of the Node.js foundation? Like what is sort of the goal of the foundation? Well, the foundation sort of the goal of the foundation? Well, the foundation is there to basically make sure that Node is stable and that it, you know, meets its potential.
整个社区是我的老板，而且我在 Linux 基金会还有一个老板。所以，是的。酷。我的意思是，这就是等级制度，对吧？每个人都是彼此的老板。对，对。这是一种看待方式。那么 Node.js 基金会的使命是什么？基金会的目标是什么？嗯，基金会的目标基本上是确保 Node 稳定，并确保它发挥其潜力。
You know, it actually reaches its potential. You know, Node has the possibility to be, you know, the largest programming language in the world and do a lot to change computing. And to make sure that it actually, you know, facilitate, like, that actually happens, we have to facilitate, you know, a healthy project with a lot of contributors, with a lot of stability and security considerations. We have to, you know, support a growing ecosystem. And we also have to, you know, support kind of more traditional marketing, PR, analyst relationships the same way that proprietary alternatives do, right?
你知道，它确实发挥了潜力。Node 有可能成为世界上最流行的编程语言，并对计算领域产生巨大影响。为了确保这一点真正发生，我们必须促进一个健康的、拥有大量贡献者的项目，并考虑稳定性和安全性。我们必须支持一个不断发展的生态系统，并且我们还必须像专有替代方案那样，支持更传统的市场营销、公关和分析师关系，对吧？
So if we're really going to change computing, we're actually going to need to compute with some of the proprietary technologies out there. Cool. So, oh, real quick. So we covered Node.js in episode 41. So if you're here to, you know, learn how to start your own server out of Node.js or something like that, go to that episode first and then come back to this one
所以，如果我们真的要改变计算领域，我们实际上需要与现有的某些专有技术进行竞争。酷。那么，快速提一下。我们在第41期节目中介绍了 Node.js。所以如果你是来学习如何用 Node.js 搭建服务器之类的，请先去听那一期，然后再回到这一期。
and learn about sort of the community that helps make that possible. Yeah, that's a good point. I don't know how much we'll get into Node.js technical details as opposed to using this resource this time with Michael to learn about open source projects. A lot of people, and we recommend people get involved with open source projects. But I'm curious, like, you curious, I start something on GitHub. It's Patrick's best new compiler for some new language, Patrick. See, I'm very ritual in my name. And it's just me working. Obviously,
然后了解一下帮助实现这一目标的社区。是的，说得好。我不知道这次我们会在多大程度上深入探讨 Node.js 的技术细节，而不是利用 Michael 的资源来学习开源项目。很多人，我们也建议人们参与开源项目。但我很好奇，比如，我在 GitHub 上启动了一个项目。它是 Patrick 的新语言的最佳新编译器，Patrick。看，我的名字很有仪式感。而且只有我在工作。显然，
that's not a foundation. There's no structure around that. What's the path of growth from the language Patrick starts getting adoption? And then like, could you kind of take us maybe through about a little bit of how something grows from me working in my basement and like by myself to a whole organization? Sure, sure. I mean, I think that, you know, most projects that we put out there don't go anywhere, you know, like, you know, even, even if you have a bunch of Twitter followers and get a followers, you know, most of the code that you put out there don't go anywhere. Even if you have a bunch of Twitter followers and GitHub followers, most of the code that you put out, nobody else uses. And part of modern open source is just kind of publishing everything and seeing where it goes.
那不是一个基金会。周围没有任何结构。当 Patrick 启动的语言开始获得采用时，增长路径是什么？你能带我们了解一下某样东西是如何从我在地下室独自工作，变成一个完整的组织的吗？当然，当然。我的意思是，我认为我们发布的大多数项目都没有下文，即使你有很多 Twitter 粉丝和 GitHub 关注者，你发布的大部分代码都没有下文。即使你有很多 Twitter 粉丝和 GitHub 关注者，你发布的大部分代码也没有人使用。现代开源的一部分就是把所有东西都发布出来，看看会发生什么。
So I have a lot of modules that are really heavily dependent on that a lot of people use, but I also have hundreds of modules that nobody cares about. And so putting stuff out the door and just engaging in the open source community is kind of the first step, right? So you just get it out there, you see what happens. If you start to get users,
所以我有很多模块，很多人都在使用，它们非常依赖这些模块，但我也有一百个没人关心的模块。所以把东西发布出去，参与开源社区是第一步，对吧？所以你把它发布出去，看看会发生什么。如果你开始有了用户，
if people actually start to depend on this thing, you're going to end up getting contributions back, right? And by contribution, I really mean any kind of engagement from another person. So they could comment on an issue, they could, you know, even people that ask for help are engaging with the project in some way. And they may send you, you know, little fixes,
如果人们真的开始依赖这个东西，你最终会得到贡献，对吧？我所说的贡献，实际上是指来自另一个人的任何形式的参与。他们可以评论一个问题，甚至那些寻求帮助的人也以某种方式参与了项目。他们可能会给你发送一些小修复、
big fixes, documentation fixes, that kind of stuff. And it's really important that as your project grows in users and as you start to see some of these new participants coming in, that you actually turn those people, at least some of them, into longer-term contributors to the project? People that may actually help review different contributions that come in or potentially in the future help you kind of run the project or do builds and things like that.
大修复、文档修复之类的东西。随着你的项目用户增长，随着你开始看到一些新参与者的加入，将这些人（至少其中一部分）转化为项目的长期贡献者是非常重要的。那些可能实际上帮助审查提交的贡献，或者在未来可能帮助你运行项目或进行构建等工作的人。
And this is the thing that I think most open source struggles with right now is that when projects start to grow, we get stuck in this single maintainer phase where it's just one person trying to handle all of the onslaught of contributions that are coming in. And that creates a lot of tension with your community because you have people that really just want help and you're just getting frustrated by the amount of help that they're trying to bring. And so we're really trying to develop a culture and a skill set and a set of guidelines for developing contributors that come in
我认为这是目前大多数开源项目都在挣扎的事情，当项目开始增长时，我们陷入了单一维护者阶段，只有一个人试图处理所有涌入的贡献。这会与你的社区产生很多紧张关系，因为有些人真的只是想要帮助，而你却因为他们试图带来的帮助量而感到沮丧。所以我们真的在努力培养一种文化、一套技能和一套指导方针，来培养加入的贡献者，
into longer-term assets, at least some percentage of them, and also making sure that projects are in a state where people can easily contribute to them and it's not very hard, so you get a lot of these smaller contributions coming in. Yeah, that makes sense. I think one thing you mentioned
使他们成为长期的资产，至少其中一部分，同时也确保项目处于一种人们可以轻松贡献的状态，这样就不会太难，从而获得大量较小的贡献。是的，这很有道理。我想你提到的
that kind of really resonated in the beginning is that, and this is true for anyone, if you do work in open source or you publish anything, most of it is going to be kind of thrown away. And I think,
在开始时引起共鸣的一点是，这对任何人来说都是真的，如果你从事开源工作或发布任何东西，大部分都会被丢弃。我想，
actually, someone, Ira Glass, did you see his talk on the creative process? Yeah, yeah. And there's some really choice quotes in it, too, just about how it's really hard for people when they first start putting out creative stuff as well. Because you're putting it out because you're kind of a fan first, and then you decide to make something. And the first stuff that you put out is just terrible. It's not up to your standards as a consumer. And you have to get over that and just keep making things and keep publishing things.
实际上，有人，Ira Glass，你看过他关于创作过程的演讲吗？是的，是的。里面有一些非常精辟的引语，关于人们在第一次发布创意作品时有多么困难。因为你发布它是因为你首先是一个粉丝，然后你决定制作一些东西。而你发布的第一批东西简直太糟糕了。它达不到你作为消费者的标准。你必须克服这一点，继续制作东西，继续发布东西。
Yeah, definitely. So going back to Patrick's, I mean, if you love doing a certain – like how – at what point do the people making Node.js say, okay, now we need a foundation? Like actually like where does the – I mean at some point companies have to be involved I suppose like to get funding and things like that? Well, I think it really depends on the needs of the project. And every project's a little different. I think that jumping to money is probably a mistake for most projects. Money and adding kind of new incentive structures can do a lot of harm to a project, to be honest. Like, for instance, if your project is really hard to contribute to, and you decide to go out
是的，绝对。回到 Patrick 的项目，如果你热爱做某事——那么制作 Node.js 的人们在什么时候说，好吧，现在我们需要一个基金会？实际上，这个点在哪里？我的意思是，在某个时候，公司必须参与进来，我想，为了获得资金之类的东西？嗯，我认为这真的取决于项目的需求。每个项目都有点不同。我认为对于大多数项目来说，直接谈钱可能是一个错误。老实说，金钱和增加新的激励结构可能会对项目造成很大伤害。例如，如果你的项目很难贡献，而你决定出去
and raise money to pay people to work on it, you're not actually going to end up making the project and the easier to contribute to. You're not going to end up getting a bunch of new contributors. It's going to retain all of those barriers to entry that it always had before. And in fact, a lot of potential contributors may look at that and go,
筹集资金来支付人们的工作，你实际上并不会让项目变得更容易贡献。你最终不会获得大量新的贡献者。它将保留它以前所有的进入壁垒。事实上，许多潜在的贡献者可能会看着它说，
well, you know what, this is maintained by people that are paid. I'm not going to even, you know, spend my time trying to engage in it. So there's a lot of kind of counter incentives that can happen too. Yeah, yeah.
好吧，你知道吗，这是由拿工资的人维护的。我甚至不会花时间去尝试参与其中。所以也会发生很多反向激励。是的，是的。
That's kind of what happened with, I believe, with Open Office because Open Office was just so heavily run by one or two industry. I think it was IBM and Sun, I think. And then no one else. There's a very strong barrier to contribute. Yeah, yeah. no one else like there wasn't there's a very strong barrier to contribute yeah yeah and and i mean you know apache has some rules about trying to uh forcibly make the contributorship diverse but there's not a lot that you can um you know really say it at the kind of process level about keeping it easy to contribute in the node project we've done a lot
这有点像我相信 Open Office 发生的事情，因为 Open Office 被一两家行业公司严重控制，我想是 IBM 和 Sun。然后没有其他人了。贡献的门槛非常高。是的，是的。没有其他人，贡献的门槛非常高。是的，是的，我的意思是，你知道 Apache 有一些规则试图强制使贡献者多样化，但在流程层面，你真的不能说太多关于保持贡献容易的事情。在 Node 项目中，我们做了很多
to make it easy to contribute um and to reduce all these barriers to entry, right? So, I mean, for one thing, the project is split into a lot of different kinds of repositories so that if you have a skill set for working on websites, you can contribute to the Node project. You don't have to be a core low-level C hacker to get involved in the project and to really make a difference. And we see a lot of people kind of level up through that process, too. They'll work on, in the evangelism repo, making blog posts, and then that'll get them into the website. And then from there, they'll go, oh, well, what does core look like? And they'll do some documentation or some test fixes.
来使贡献变得容易，并减少所有这些进入壁垒，对吧？所以，一方面，项目被拆分成许多不同类型的存储库，所以如果你有从事网站工作的技能，你就可以为 Node 项目做出贡献。你不必成为核心底层 C 语言黑客才能参与项目并真正有所作为。我们也看到很多人通过这个过程提升了自己。他们会在宣传存储库中工作，撰写博客文章，然后这会让他们进入网站。然后从那里，他们会说，哦，核心看起来是什么样的？他们会做一些文档或测试修复。
And then all of a sudden, they're sticking around and really getting deep into the code. And we have a record number of contributors to Node now. We have, I think, over 70 committers. So about a year ago, it was five. Or like a year and a half ago now, I guess. Just the TSC, the governing body around core, I think, is like 18 people now. There's just a ton of contributors. I think in the latest release, we updated the author's file from about three months ago,
然后突然之间，他们留下来并深入研究代码。我们现在有创纪录的 Node 贡献者数量。我想我们有超过 70 名提交者。所以大约一年前，是五个。或者我想现在是一年半前了。仅仅是 TSC，围绕核心的治理机构，我想现在有 18 个人。有大量的贡献者。我想在最新的版本中，我们更新了三个月前的作者文件，
and I think like 120 people were added to it um that are just outside contributors yeah and a lot of it is just you know making it really easy to contribute i think that you know if you look at um the github data on this like the majority of work happening pushes and commits that are going into the github ecosystem are coming from people that commit like less than 20 times a month, right? People that are not super highly engaged. The people that are highly engaged account for like a shrinking percentage of the total workload. And I think that this is really hard for projects to kind of wrap their head around because the people that show up every day are the people that have a voice and that tend to have power and that tend to create the process in most projects.
我想大约增加了 120 个人，他们只是外部贡献者。是的，很多只是让贡献变得非常容易。我认为，如果你查看 GitHub 上的数据，GitHub 生态系统中发生的大部分工作、推送和提交都来自那些每月提交少于 20 次的人，对吧？那些不是超级高度参与的人。高度参与的人占总工作量的比例在缩小。我认为这对项目来说很难理解，因为每天出现的人是那些有发言权、倾向于拥有权力并倾向于在大多数项目中创建流程的人。
And it's very hard for those people to create a process that's not for them. It's actually for people that are less engaged because the people that show up every day are going to show up every day no matter what. Oh, I see. So you've got to actually make it easier on other people. And obviously, I mean, you know,
这些人很难创建一个不是为他们自己，而是为那些参与度较低的人服务的流程，因为每天出现的人无论如何都会出现。哦，我明白了。所以你必须让其他人更容易参与。显然，我的意思是，
I don't really think that there's a one size fits all process for this. You know, if you look across the Node.js project, we have different policies around contribution in different repositories because, you know, the Node core project just has different constraints than the, you know, website. Right. And so we can make the website incredibly easy to contribute to and not, you know, worry about things like, you know, comment metadata. But in the core project, we really need to make sure that that stuff is really clean because we have to do all these branch merges and all this other complicated stuff. Oh, I see.
我真的不认为有一个适合所有人的流程。如果你看看 Node.js 项目，我们在不同的存储库中有不同的贡献政策，因为 Node 核心项目与网站有不同的约束。对。所以我们可以让网站变得非常容易贡献，而不必担心像评论元数据之类的事情。但在核心项目中，我们真的需要确保这些东西非常干净，因为我们必须进行所有这些分支合并和所有其他复杂的事情。哦，我明白了。
So what if you have to do something kind of atomic, like I'm trying to think of a good example, like HTTP three comes out and, and you have to update to HTTP three. It's a massive change and kind of everyone has to be on board because it changes everything. How do you sort of coordinate that when you have so many people all across the globe?
那么，如果你必须做一些原子性的事情，比如我想想一个好的例子，比如 HTTP/3 出来了，你必须更新到 HTTP/3。这是一个巨大的变化，每个人都必须参与，因为它改变了一切。当你全球有这么多人时，你如何协调这一点？
Right, right. So yeah, that, that touches on a lot of things that we have in, in the node core project. So I'll touch on a couple of them. One is that when a new contribution comes in from anybody, the default assumption is that it will land. So we don't say, you know, convince us that this should make it in. It's actually up to all of the committers. And now we have over 70 committers, right? It's up to them to say reasons why something should not go in and basically have corrections. So the review process is the series of corrections
对，对。所以这触及了我们在 Node 核心项目中拥有的许多东西。所以我谈谈其中的几个。一是当任何人的新贡献进来时，默认假设是它会落地。所以我们不会说，说服我们这应该被采纳。实际上取决于所有的提交者，现在我们有超过 70 名提交者，对吧？由他们来说明为什么某事不应该被采纳，并基本上进行修正。所以审查过程是一系列修正，
to make this thing land. And there's sort of like a benefit of the doubt thing, right? We also bend towards things happening. So we don't escalate, we don't ask for votes, anything where somebody's not objecting to it, Right. So until somebody says, you know, this probably shouldn't go in or I have a problem with this. That's when things get escalated and we actually bring them to a vote in the CTC, which is basically a bunch of committers that are a little bit more trusted with the technical parts of the project. So this is like called like a consensus seeking where um you try to reach a consensus if nobody objects things just land um and that's over 90 of the contributions that come to court just land that way they don't have to get escalated they don't need to vote uh we don't have a lot of like burdensome process in the way of getting things in um also part of that whole review process is
使这个东西落地。有一种疑罪从无的东西，对吧？我们也倾向于事情发生。所以我们不会升级，我们不会要求投票，任何没有人反对的事情，对吧。所以直到有人说，这可能不应该被采纳，或者我对这个有意见。那时事情才会升级，我们实际上会把它们提交给 CTC 投票，这基本上是一群在项目的技术部分更受信任的提交者。所以这被称为寻求共识，你试图达成共识，如果没有人反对，事情就会落地，超过 90% 的核心贡献就是这样落地的。它们不需要升级，不需要投票，我们没有很多繁琐的流程阻碍事情的进展。此外，整个审查过程的一部分是
that um changes need to sit for like between two and three days, depending on if it's a weekend or not. And that's because we have people all over the world in every time zone that need to have a chance to review code that's coming in. Oh, that's true. I didn't think about that. But yeah, if you get someone in Germany who really objects and you send it off at, you know, 3 PM Pacific time, that person's voice won't be heard. Totally. And this at 3 p.m. Pacific time, that person's voice won't be heard.
变化需要停留两到三天，取决于是否是周末。这是因为我们在世界各地每个时区都有人，他们需要有机会审查进来的代码。哦，那是真的。我没考虑到这一点。但是的，如果你在德国有一个人真的反对，而你在太平洋时间下午 3 点发送它，那个人的声音就不会被听到。完全正确。在太平洋时间下午 3 点，那个人的声音就不会被听到。
Totally. And this is really important for us. I mean, we have a lot of skill sets around the NodeCore project. I mean, most people don't have a crypto expert, and we're lucky enough to have two people that really know the OpenSSL code base really well. And they're in Moscow and Japan. So we need to make sure that, especially when security stuff is going in,
完全正确。这对我们来说非常重要。我的意思是，我们在 Node 核心项目周围有很多技能。我的意思是，大多数人没有加密专家，我们很幸运有两个人非常了解 OpenSSL 代码库。他们在莫斯科和日本。所以我们需要确保，特别是在安全相关的东西进来时，
that they have a chance to weigh in. And, you know, I mean, the TSC lead is in Australia. One of the longest contributors is in, like outside of Amsterdam. You know, obviously there's a bunch of people from the US and other countries in. So we just have people all over the world, and we need to make sure that everybody can participate
他们有机会发表意见。而且，我的意思是，TSC 负责人是在澳大利亚。最长期的贡献者之一在阿姆斯特丹之外。你知道，显然有很多来自美国和其他国家的人。所以我们只是在世界各地都有人，我们需要确保每个人都能参与
in the reviews. So that's been really, really critical. And I think one of the things, too, is that if you look at the Node project, we don't have a really stringent roadmap of, like, this feature is going to land on this date, and then this feature is going to land on that date um our roadmap just says you know this is when we're doing our next uh major release that will probably be a breaking release um and this is how long our long-term
审查。所以这非常非常关键。而且我认为其中一点是，如果你看看 Node 项目，我们没有一个非常严格的路线图，比如这个功能将在这一天落地，然后那个功能将在那一天落地。我们的路线图只是说，这是我们进行下一次重大发布的时间，那可能是一个破坏性的发布，这是我们的长期
support cycle is um and this is actually this allows anybody to get anything in because we're not saying you know this stuff is more important than stuff it's if you care about something you want to get it in, it can probably land. If you want to get something into Node, send us a pull request, get things moving, and we'll work on getting that code in. And this has led actually just to a lot more people getting stuff in and a lot more even really big changes just because people know that they're not going to be pushed in the back burner just because it's not part of some roadmap. So that works for the bottom-up kind of changes. But yeah, like Jason was asking about a more overarching direction. How do those things get set and how does that get coordinated?
支持周期是多久。这实际上允许任何人获得任何东西，因为我们不是说这些东西比那些东西更重要。如果你关心某事，你想让它进来，它很可能落地。如果你想让某事进入 Node，给我们发送一个拉取请求，让事情动起来，我们会努力让代码进来。这实际上导致了更多的人把东西放进来，甚至是非常大的变化，只是因为人们知道他们不会因为不是某个路线图的一部分而被推到后台。所以这对于自下而上的变化很有效。但是，就像 Jason 问的关于更宏观的方向。这些事情是如何设定的，又是如何协调的？
Right. a lot of that because we tend to take an ecosystem approach to the project where we want a diverse and flourishing ecosystem on top of Node. We don't want Node to become everything to everyone. And those are always kind of count like, you know, those are conflicting forces, right? Like, I think that one of the reasons why Python doesn't have a huge module community is because Python core continues to grow this giant standard library. And one of the reasons why we have the largest module ecosystem in the world is because we've kept core very small. So we don't do a ton of giant shifts in one direction or another.
对。很多是因为我们倾向于对项目采取生态系统方法，我们希望在 Node 之上有一个多样化和繁荣的生态系统。我们不希望 Node 成为每个人的万能工具。这些总是相互冲突的力量，对吧？就像，我认为 Python 没有庞大的模块社区的原因之一是 Python 核心继续发展这个巨大的标准库。而我们拥有世界上最大模块生态系统的原因之一是我们保持核心非常小。所以我们不会在一个方向或另一个方向上进行大量的巨大转变。
We do have certain large-scale, high-impact features. One would be this feature called AsyncWrap, which is about really low-level instrumentation and debuggability that could completely destroy performance if it were done wrong. We also are talking about how we might add support for ES6 modules, and that's a big discussion. And for those things where we really need to get alignment about this before we sit down to write code, the way that they're done is with this thing called an EPS and an improvement proposal, or enhancement proposal, sorry. And it's just a spec. It's a markdown spec where we, and we do it as a pull request in a separate repository. And then once the pull request kind of, we use the same kind of process that you would for reviewing code, it's just the spec instead.
我们确实有一些大规模、高影响力的功能。一个是名为 AsyncWrap 的功能，它是关于非常底层的检测和可调试性，如果做错了可能会完全破坏性能。我们也在讨论我们如何可能添加对 ES6 模块的支持，这是一个很大的讨论。对于那些我们需要在坐下来写代码之前达成一致的事情，它们是通过一种叫做 EPS 的东西完成的，即改进提案，或者增强提案，抱歉。它只是一个规范。它是一个 Markdown 规范，我们在一个单独的存储库中将其作为拉取请求。然后一旦拉取请求，我们使用与审查代码相同的流程，只是它是规范而已。
And then, you know, that eventually goes up for the CTC, so that, you know, the project can say yes is the direction we go, yes we want to add this before anybody goes and sits down to write hundreds of thousands of lines of code. Okay, that makes sense. What about, like,
然后，那最终会提交给 CTC，以便项目可以说这是我们前进的方向，是的，我们想在任何人坐下来写几十万行代码之前添加这个。好的，这很有道理。那么，
do you guys ever meet face-to-face? Like, do you have a convention somewhere and say, hey, everyone, all the Node.js committers can come to this place at this time and hang out, grab a beer or something? Well, we have a few too many people to claim that all will be at anything. Right, right. It's just a little bit too big. But yeah, so the foundation runs two major events this year,
你们会面对面开会吗？比如，你们在某个地方有一个大会，说，嘿，大家，所有的 Node.js 提交者都可以来这个地方，在那个时间聚会，喝杯啤酒什么的？嗯，我们的人太多了，无法声称所有人都会参加任何事情。对，对。它太大了。但是的，基金会今年举办了两个主要活动，
Node.js Interactive in Amsterdam and in Austin. And part of that is a collaborator summit, which is more of like an unconference where people who are active and committing and working on the project just get together and try to hash some stuff out. And we're also doing this thing called the Code and Learn, which is that if you want to work on Node Core
Node.js Interactive 在阿姆斯特丹和奥斯汀。其中一部分是合作者峰会，这更像是一个非会议，活跃的、提交代码和从事项目工作的人聚在一起，试图解决一些问题。我们还在做一件叫做 Code and Learn 的事情，就是如果你想从事 Node 核心工作，
and you want to get deeply embedded in something, but you want just like a day's worth of mentorship to kind of dive in, we have all the contributors there that can help you do that. And then, of course, we have all the regular kind regular talks by core people and stuff like that at the regular conference that happens as well oh very cool so we get one of our most common
并且你想深入嵌入到某件事中，但你只是想要一天的指导来深入研究，我们有所有的贡献者在那里可以帮助你做到这一点。当然，我们还有所有常规的由核心人员进行的演讲之类的，在常规会议上也发生。哦，非常酷。所以我们收到最常见的问题之一，
questions, email questions in are people who want to work on an open source project but they've literally just picked a book on C++ 101 and so then they try and jump into Node.js for example and they don't really know where to start.
电子邮件问题是人们想从事开源项目，但他们实际上只是刚拿起一本 C++ 101 的书，然后他们试图跳进 Node.js，例如，他们真的不知道从哪里开始。
Is there, I mean, what would be your advice to somebody who maybe just graduated from college, knows nothing about Node, but they want to sort of donate their time? Or maybe they're a Node user, but they use Express or something, but they know nothing about the Node code base, but they want to help. What's something, even maybe something small that they can do to get started? I tend to look at this in terms of barriers to entry.
有没有，我的意思是，你会给那些刚从大学毕业，对 Node 一无所知，但他们想捐献时间的人什么建议？或者他们是 Node 用户，但他们使用 Express 之类的，但他们对 Node 代码库一无所知，但他们想帮忙。有什么事情，甚至可能是他们可以做的很小的事情来开始？我倾向于从进入壁垒的角度来看待这个问题。
There's two categories of barriers to entry. One is technical and one is cultural. So if you want to work on a new project, you may have to learn technical things in order to get over a hump. But then you also have to acclimate to how this project works and how things happen. And it's a little daunting to go after both of those at the same time. So I tend to encourage people to look at the project and look at their skill set and do something that they already know how to do, right? So you can adjust documentation, you can adjust a test pretty easily, basically anywhere. You can work on the website, you can help write a blog post. There are all these different areas in the core project
进入壁垒有两类。一个是技术的，一个是文化的。所以如果你想从事一个新项目，你可能必须学习技术知识才能克服障碍。但你还必须适应这个项目是如何工作的，事情是如何发生的。同时追求这两者有点令人生畏。所以我倾向于鼓励人们看看项目，看看他们的技能，做一些他们已经知道怎么做的事情，对吧？所以你可以调整文档，你可以很容易地调整测试，基本上在任何地方。你可以从事网站工作，你可以帮助写博客文章。核心项目中有所有这些不同的领域，
that you can contribute to where most people that will listen to this podcast will have some kind of skill set around web development or documentation that could do that. And, you know, that's like a good way to dip your toe in the water. And that's a good way to only acclimate to the cultural part and really just kind of figure out how things work. And, you know, make sure that this is like a nice welcoming community that's not, that you actually want to be a part of. So I would encourage people to do that first. And we have a couple tags across the project, like, you know, good first contribution and things like that, that are, you know, good kind of low hanging fruit. But yeah, that's what I encourage people to do for sure.
你可以贡献，大多数听这个播客的人都会有一些关于 Web 开发或文档的技能可以做到这一点。而且，那是一种试水的好方法。这也是一种只适应文化部分，真正弄清楚事情是如何运作的好方法。而且，确保这是一个不错的、受欢迎的社区，不是，你实际上想成为其中的一部分。所以我鼓励人们先做那个。我们在整个项目中都有几个标签，比如，好的第一次贡献之类的，它们是好的低垂的果实。但是是的，这绝对是我鼓励人们做的。
So if you want to acquaint yourself with the community, with the cadence, with the direction, with that kind of stuff, is it typically that open source projects are using mailing lists for that? IRC chats? You want to be an observer. I want to get interested, but like you said, before I invest all this time,
所以如果你想熟悉社区、节奏、方向之类的东西，通常开源项目是使用邮件列表吗？IRC 聊天？你想成为一个观察者。我想感兴趣，但就像你说的，在我投入所有时间之前，
I want to kind of get up to speed because there's this embarrassment thing that you're worried about, right? Like, I'm going to send an email and this person is going to think I'm really stupid. Now, there's various issues with that, but, you know, that's kind of how people feel. And so you want to kind of sit on the sidelines and just watch what's going by before kind of stepping in and helping. And what is the best way to kind of figure out where the quote unquote community lives? Right. So for us, everything is on GitHub.
我想赶上进度，因为有这种尴尬的事情，你担心，对吧？比如，我会发一封电子邮件，这个人会认为我很蠢。现在，这有各种各样的问题，但，你知道，这就是人们的感觉。所以你想坐在场边，看着正在发生的事情，然后再介入和帮助。弄清楚所谓的社区住在哪里，最好的方法是什么？对。所以对我们来说，一切都在 GitHub 上。
We actually, we don't have mailing lists we we basically treat the github issue tracker almost like a mailing list um and uh inside of the node js github org which is just github slash node js there's like a hundred repositories right and um you know each one kind of covers a different area um the best way to figure out where your thing is that you might want to be interested in is that there's a repository just called help. So just GitHub slash Node.js slash help. And in there, you can ask any question that you want. So it could be about, I don't know how to do this thing in Node.
我们实际上，我们没有邮件列表，我们基本上把 GitHub 问题跟踪器几乎当作邮件列表，在 Node.js GitHub 组织内部，也就是 github.com/nodejs，有大约一百个存储库，每个存储库涵盖不同的领域。弄清楚你可能感兴趣的东西在哪里的最好方法是，有一个名为 help 的存储库。所以只需 github.com/nodejs/help。在那里，你可以问任何你想问的问题。所以它可以是关于，我不知道如何在 Node 中做这件事。
Or it could be, you know what, like, I have this kind of skill set. What are the things that I should, like the repositories that I should watch? Or how should I kind of get involved in this particular area? And people there will tell you how to get involved. So the answer to that question really depends on the individual person's skill set and what they want to work on. But we do have a place where you can figure that out. Nice.
或者它可以是，你知道吗，我有这种技能。我应该关注哪些存储库？或者我应该如何参与这个特定领域？那里的人会告诉你如何参与。所以那个问题的答案真的取决于个人的技能和他们想从事的工作。但我们确实有一个地方可以让你弄清楚这一点。不错。
So you brought up something else, which is I'm using Node.js and I have a question. And what does kind of the Node.js foundation of the project do? Because obviously for it to continue to be important, people need to be using it. Like just developing Node.js is awesome, but if no one uses it, kind of what's the point?
所以你提到了另一件事，就是我正在使用 Node.js，我有一个问题。Node.js 基金会或项目做什么？因为显然为了让它继续重要，人们需要使用它。仅仅开发 Node.js 很棒，但如果没人使用它，那有什么意义？
Like, I mean, there is a point, but like past a certain level, right? And so how do you kind of help try to make sure that the people using it are facilitated, have the help they need, have a healthy blog post about how do you write projects in Node.js, as well as contributing to Node.js? Right. So I think this is actually one of Node's strengths.
我的意思是，有一个意义，但在一定水平之后，对吧？所以你如何帮助确保使用它的人得到促进，得到他们需要的帮助，有关于如何在 Node.js 中编写项目的健康博客文章，以及为 Node.js 做出贡献？对。所以我认为这实际上是 Node 的优势之一。
And I mean, we have 100% year-over-year growth right now. It's tremendous how fast we're growing in terms of users. And a big part of that is that we have a wealth of almost anarchistic resources about learning Node and doing things in Node. And that actually turns out to be a big asset because different types of developers just look for different types of information
我的意思是，我们现在有 100% 的同比增长。我们在用户方面增长的速度非常惊人。很大一部分原因是，我们拥有大量关于学习 Node 和在 Node 中做事情的几乎无政府状态的资源。这实际上被证明是一个巨大的资产，因为不同类型的开发人员只是寻找不同类型的信息，
when they're working through things. There are certain developers that will just bang at something until it doesn't work and then they'll Google something. And then hopefully that lands them on like a stack overflow article or a blog post that's like related to what they're doing um and we have a ton of those kinds of resources up we have um you know we have api documentation we have node school which is like this tremendous community of people putting together uh self-guided workshops and also just around the world
当他们处理事情时。有些开发人员会一直敲打某件事直到它不起作用，然后他们会 Google 一些东西。然后希望这能让他们找到像 Stack Overflow 文章或与他们正在做的事情相关的博客文章，我们有很多那种资源，我们有 API 文档，我们有 Node School，这是一个庞大的社区，人们聚集在一起进行自导工作坊，而且在世界各地
doing little meetup workshops and getting people into Node and learning Node. So we have all of these different types of resources for different types of learners that people tend to find. And if you're looking for, if you don't know what type of resource to find, I would go to that Node.js slash help repo and just ask there.
做小型的聚会工作坊，让人们进入 Node 并学习 Node。所以我们有所有这些不同类型的资源，供不同类型的学习者使用，人们往往会找到。如果你正在寻找，如果你不知道要找什么类型的资源，我会去那个 Node.js/help 存储库并直接在那里问。
And you'll definitely get a good answer. But yeah, I think that, you know, a lot of projects tend to focus on, you know, one true answer for this kind of stuff. Like, you know, we have perfect documentation, and it's all right here. And, you know, we have API documentation. But we also have, you know, just a million things that you find on Google, from traditional published books to, you know, self-guided workshoppers to just stack up with little articles. Nice. Yeah. And then what about establishing like standards? You talked about Python. So Python kind of has their like, here's the way to write Python. Now you can write
你肯定会得到一个好的答案。但是的，我认为，很多项目倾向于关注这种事情的唯一正确答案。比如，我们有完美的文档，它就在这里。而且，我们有 API 文档。但我们也有你在 Google 上找到的数百万种东西，从传统的出版书籍到自导工作坊，再到 Stack Overflow 的小文章。不错。是的。那么建立标准呢？你谈到了 Python。所以 Python 有点像，这是编写 Python 的方式。现在你可以
it however you want, but you know, they kind of have, right. Yeah. So they kind of have, I don't know exactly their relationship of pet bait to them, but there exists a standard. Let's pretend they did it for now so I don't have to Google it. But that's kind of one attitude. One attitude is to say, look, I don't care how you write it. Do what you want. But obviously people who know what they're doing are a good resource to say, what's the right way to structure a program, to have module decomposition, that kind of stuff.
随心所欲地写，但你知道，他们有一种，对。是的。所以他们有一种，我不知道他们与 PEP 的确切关系，但存在一个标准。让我们假装他们现在做了，这样我就不必去 Google 了。但那是一种态度。一种态度是说，看，我不在乎你怎么写。做你想做的。但显然知道自己在做什么的人是一个很好的资源，可以说，构建程序的正确方法是什么，进行模块分解，那种东西。
How do you help shepherd the community from that standpoint? So I think Node stays out of this more than probably any other language. There's a lot of creativity in the JavaScript community, and we don't want to tell people what our opinion on semicolons is and try to say that that's the one true way or anything like that. I think that there are, though, a few core patterns that Node defines, and a lot of compatibility with Node itself and with modules in the ecosystem
你如何从那个角度帮助引导社区？所以我认为 Node 在这方面比任何其他语言都保持得更远。JavaScript 社区有很多创造力，我们不想告诉人们我们对分号的看法，并试图说那是唯一正确的方法之类的。但我认为，确实有几个 Node 定义的核心模式，以及与 Node 本身和生态系统中模块的许多兼容性
depend on those patterns. So if you're doing iterative processing of data, you would use streams, and that's really important. There's sort of a standard callback API that all the Node APIs use and that most modules in the ecosystem use, and that's a really important kind of core pattern so that people can use that. That's just the error first callback pattern.
取决于这些模式。所以如果你正在进行数据的迭代处理，你会使用流，这非常重要。有一种标准的回调 API，所有的 Node API 都使用它，生态系统中的大多数模块也使用它，这是一个非常重要的核心模式，这样人们就可以使用它。那就是错误优先回调模式。
It's very, very simple. And I think, you know, for publishing modules to NPM, there's something of a best practice there, which is that a module should be a single function and should, you know, do something very well. And so most modules that you see published to NPM are a single function that do a single thing. And they're usually composed of like 100 other modules to get that thing done. But those are really the only patterns
它非常非常简单。而且我认为，对于发布模块到 NPM，那里有一些最佳实践，即一个模块应该是一个单一的函数，并且应该做某事做得很好。所以你在 NPM 上看到的大多数模块都是一个单一的函数，做一件事。它们通常由其他 100 个模块组成来完成那件事。但那些确实是唯一的模式，
that we kind of push and advocate in the community. We don't push a particular style guide. We don't really even have an opinion about higher level constructs like promises. We're really kind of trying to stay out of that and let the ecosystem decide what they want to do. The only other thing that we do a little bit more proactively
我们在社区中推动和倡导。我们不推动特定的风格指南。我们甚至对像 Promise 这样的高级结构没有意见。我们真的试图远离那个，让生态系统决定他们想做什么。我们唯一更主动做的事情
is that as new language features land in V8 and then we take the versions of V8, we do a fair amount of work to figure out what is optimized and what isn't and what is fast and what isn't. Mostly just so that in Node itself, we can know which features to use and not to use. And then we let the community kind of know which of those
是随着新的语言功能进入 V8，然后我们采用 V8 的版本，我们做了相当多的工作来弄清楚什么是优化的，什么不是，什么是快的，什么不是。主要是为了在 Node 本身中，我们可以知道使用哪些功能，不使用哪些。然后我们让社区知道哪些
features are already optimized and which are not. So that's actually interesting. So you talked about V8. Maybe could you talk briefly about kind of Node's relationship to V8? And then also like V8 isn't Node, you know, at least in my understanding. And so like depending on another project, right,
功能已经优化，哪些没有。所以这实际上很有趣。所以你谈到了 V8。也许你能简要谈谈 Node 与 V8 的关系？然后还有 V8 不是 Node，你知道，至少在我的理解中。所以依赖另一个项目，对吧，
has its own good parts and bad parts, and talk about how Node manages that. So I think V8 is the JavaScript engine that Google made for Chrome. And Node has always bounded this VM and has used it for a very, very long time. Every major release of Node usually comes with a new V8. And that, up until this last one,
有它自己的好坏部分，谈谈 Node 如何管理这一点。所以我认为 V8 是 Google 为 Chrome 制作的 JavaScript 引擎。Node 一直绑定这个 VM，并且已经使用了很长很长时间。Node 的每个主要版本通常都带有新的 V8。而且，直到上一个版本，
that meant that the C++ API would break. The Chrome team, like the, because the Google manages Chrome and V8 kind of together, they don't mind breaking their binding layer because they can just update the Chrome code. But in the Node ecosystem, if you have
这意味着 C++ API 会中断。Chrome 团队，因为 Google 同时管理 Chrome 和 V8，他们不介意破坏他们的绑定层，因为他们可以更新 Chrome 代码。但在 Node 生态系统中，如果你有
any native modules, anything that's written in C, C++, this causes a big problem, and it takes a while for the ecosystem to upgrade. So that's one of the reasons why Node has a longer major release cycle than V8 does. V8 has a major release every six weeks, and we only have one every six months.
任何原生模块，任何用 C 或 C++ 编写的东西，都会导致很大的问题，而且生态系统升级需要一段时间。这就是为什么 Node 的主要版本发布周期比 V8 更长的原因之一。V8 每六周发布一个主要版本，而我们每六个月才发布一个。
But for a while, there was really not a lot of communication between V8 and Node, to be honest. It really kind of broke down a couple of years ago where it got pretty close to zero communication between the V8 team and Node. But really, since IOJS and since IOJS merged into the foundation and there's really a foundation in place,
但老实说，有一段时间 V8 和 Node 之间确实没有太多沟通。几年前，V8 团队和 Node 团队之间的沟通几乎降到了零，关系确实破裂了。但自从 IOJS 出现，以及 IOJS 合并到基金会并真正建立起基金会之后，
the V8 team is getting more and more integrated into the Node process. And in fact, certain resources from the Google Cloud platform, which is heavily investing in Node, are also working on Node for Google that aren't specific to the VA team. So that's really created a better relationship with us. And I think that they care a lot more
V8 团队正越来越多地融入到 Node 的流程中。事实上，谷歌云平台的一些资源（该平台在 Node 上投入了大量资金）也在为谷歌从事 Node 相关工作，而不仅仅是针对 V8 团队。这确实为我们建立了更好的关系。而且我认为他们更加关心
about that kind of API stability. And we're working with them to maybe bring an end to these breaking changes to the C++ API. So that's actually going really, really well. And in addition to that, at the same time is that you have the Chakra team from Microsoft binding Node to Chakra, getting Node onto the Xbox and to Windows 10 IoT by binding it to Chakra. And you also have the Spider Node project, which actually started, I think, back in 2010, but is now actually updated and working again for the first time in like five years.
那种 API 的稳定性。我们正在与他们合作，或许可以终结这些对 C++ API 的破坏性更改。所以这方面进展得非常非常顺利。此外，与此同时，微软的 Chakra 团队正在将 Node 绑定到 Chakra，通过绑定到 Chakra 让 Node 运行在 Xbox 和 Windows 10 IoT 上。你还有 Spider Node 项目，我想它实际上始于 2010 年，但现在已经更新并重新工作了，这是五年来第一次。
And that's binding Node to SpiderMonkey. And so I think in the future, we'll probably see a slightly more VM-neutral Node.js than we have in the past, although I don't see any time soon where the default won't be V8. Interesting. I've done a lot of Node projects. I'm a huge fan. And I saw IO.js kind of come and go on Hacker News.
那是将 Node 绑定到 SpiderMonkey。所以我认为在未来，我们可能会看到一个比过去稍微更具 VM 中立性的 Node.js，尽管我不认为默认引擎很快就会不再是 V8。很有趣。我做过很多 Node 项目。我是它的忠实粉丝。我看到 IO.js 在 Hacker News 上出现又消失。
I never actually took the time to find out what it is. It's some kind of fork of Node.js, but now it's merged back. Can you kind of talk me through that? Sure. So there was a disagreement with the owner-steward of Node.js, Joyent, and some of the contributors
我从来没有花时间去了解它是什么。它似乎是 Node.js 的某种分支，但现在又合并回去了。你能给我讲讲吗？当然。当时 Node.js 的所有者兼管理者 Joyent 与社区中一些为 Node 做出贡献的贡献者之间存在分歧，
that were in the community contributing to Node. And the disagreement wasn't about technical direction, really. There were clearly a lot of problems that Node needed to solve. But the real disagreement was just about how the project was run, right? Is this a governance structure? Is this a BDFL model? How do we have
分歧其实并不在于技术方向。Node 确实有很多问题需要解决。但真正的分歧在于项目的管理方式，对吧？这是一种治理结构吗？这是一种仁慈独裁者（BDFL）模式吗？我们如何在我们投入大量时间的这个项目中拥有
more of a voice in this thing that we're dedicating a lot of our time to? For people who don't know out there, so BDFL is Benevolent Dictator for Life. And so that came from Python where Guido had the final say on everything. No, it came from Linux. Oh, it came from Linux. Yeah, yeah. Linux is the BDFL of Linux.
更多的话语权？对于那些不知道的人，BDFL 是“仁慈独裁者终身制”（Benevolent Dictator for Life）。这源于 Python，Guido 对一切拥有最终决定权。不，它源于 Linux。哦，它源于 Linux。是的，是的。Linus 是 Linux 的 BDFL。
Oh, okay. Yeah, yeah. But yeah, and so Node had a BDFL, but it would turn over every two or three years. So it was Benevolent Dictator for two or three years. So it was a benevolent dictator for two or three years. That acronym is way harder. Right, right. And I think as the community around Node grew, the user base grew,
哦，好吧。是的，是的。但 Node 确实有一位 BDFL，但他每两三年就会轮换一次。所以它是“两三年制仁慈独裁者”。所以它是“两三年制仁慈独裁者”。那个缩写词难记多了。对，对。而且我认为随着 Node 周围社区的壮大，用户群的增长，
the amount of outside contributions kind of coming in grew, the number of committers and maintainers was not growing. It was not keeping up. So the model of managing a project was just not scaling with what was happening to Node. And so the people behind IOJS thought that they had a lot of good ideas about scaling out the project,
外部贡献的数量在增加，但提交者和维护者的数量却没有增长。它跟不上步伐。所以管理项目的模式根本无法随着 Node 的发展而扩展。因此，IOJS 背后的那些人认为，他们在扩展项目方面有很多好的想法，
really learning from Node's own ecosystem. There were a lot of great kind of governance experiments in the Node.js ecosystem. And so they created this fork under this other governance model. Most of the committers to Node went over to IO.js. And that model worked incredibly well. I mean, it, you know, I think in three or four months, it became, sorry, it hit a record high in the number of people contributing to Node.js. So back, like, you know, it was like 2012 since it had been that high. And then they eventually kind of broke that record. So it was a tremendous success in terms of bringing in new people to the project.
真正从 Node 自身的生态系统中吸取了经验。Node.js 生态系统中有很多很棒的治理实验。于是，他们在这种不同的治理模式下创建了这个分支。大多数 Node 的提交者都转到了 IO.js。那种模式运作得非常好。我的意思是，我认为在三四个月内，它就达到了，抱歉，它在 Node.js 的贡献人数上创下了历史新高。所以回到，你知道，自 2012 年以来就没达到过那么高。然后他们最终打破了那个记录。所以在吸引新人加入项目方面，它取得了巨大的成功。
You know, it wasn't super stable, right? Because, you know, doing really fast iteration, taking V8 all the time, doing all these major breaks. But because it's not Node.js, and, you know, people were kind of opting into the fork, didn't really have to deal with the long-term stability issues that Node had to deal with because it didn't have any history yet. But at the end of the day, there was no technical disagreement. There was no like, oh, we want Node to have more features or we want Node to go in this direction or that. It was just about how to manage the project. And so Joyent decided to start the Node Foundation and put Node into
你知道，它并不是特别稳定，对吧？因为，你知道，进行非常快速的迭代，一直采用 V8，进行所有这些重大的破坏性更改。但因为它不是 Node.js，而且，你知道，人们是选择加入这个分支的，所以它不需要处理 Node 必须处理的长期稳定性问题，因为它还没有任何历史。但归根结底，并没有技术上的分歧。并没有说，哦，我们希望 Node 有更多功能，或者我们希望 Node 往这个方向或那个方向发展。这只是关于如何管理项目。所以 Joyent 决定成立 Node 基金会，并将 Node 放入
a foundation. Once Node was into a foundation, the IOJS group decided to merge in. And essentially, the foundation for Node.js adopted more or less the governance model from IOJS. So all those contributors came in, all that process came in. But now a lot of new things needed to happen in terms of release scheduling and long-term support to bring all of these new contributors in this community to support something that needs to remain stable for years and years. Right. Um, so, and it would, I mean, it's been a huge success. Like it took a lot of work from, from,
一个基金会中。一旦 Node 进入基金会，IOJS 小组就决定合并进来。本质上，Node.js 基金会或多或少采用了 IOJS 的治理模式。所以所有那些贡献者都进来了，所有那些流程也都进来了。但现在，在发布计划和长期支持方面，需要发生很多新的事情，以吸引所有这些新的贡献者加入这个社区，来支持一个需要保持多年稳定的东西。对。嗯，所以，我的意思是，这取得了巨大的成功。就像它花费了我和 James Snellen 以及 Rod Vegg 的大量工作，
you know, me and James Snellen and Rod Vegg to make all this stuff happen. But at the end of the day, we have, um, both like the, the stability of Node.js with the competencies of open governance and a huge amount of a growing contribution base from IO.js. So we really got to take both of the core competencies and merge them together. So that was great. Cool.
才让这一切成为现实。但归根结底，我们拥有 Node.js 的稳定性，以及开放治理的能力，还有来自 IO.js 的大量不断增长的贡献基础。所以我们真的能够取长补短，将它们合并在一起。这太棒了。酷。
Cool. Totally makes sense. So IO.js now is merged in. So you get all of those features by using the latest Node.js? Yeah, so as of version 4, the last IOJS version was version 3, and so version 4 of Node.js was the IOJS merge, essentially. Gotcha. Cool. Very cool. So what is, you know, you're a community manager. And so someone who's community manager of an open source foundation, what's sort of your day to day like? What are sort of the things that you kind of typically have on your plate? Or just in general, like the Node.js foundation? What are kind of the day-to-day activities there? So, I mean, with a community that's growing, you know, it's doubling every year, that kind of always changes, right? I think, you know, really early on, I was much more involved in the kind of day-to-day of the project because we were doing this huge merge to bring these communities together and we were still kind of
酷。完全说得通。所以 IO.js 现在已经合并进来了。所以通过使用最新的 Node.js，你就能获得所有这些功能？是的，从第 4 版开始，最后一个 IOJS 版本是第 3 版，所以 Node.js 的第 4 版本质上就是 IOJS 的合并。明白了。酷。非常酷。那么，你知道，你是一位社区经理。作为一个开源基金会的社区经理，你的日常工作是什么样的？你通常手头会有什么事情？或者就整个 Node.js 基金会而言，那里的日常活动是什么？所以，我的意思是，随着社区的壮大，你知道，它每年都在翻倍，这种情况总是会改变，对吧？我想，你知道，在早期，我更多地参与了项目的日常工作，因为我们正在进行这次巨大的合并，将这些社区聚集在一起，而且我们仍在
coming up with the practices and processes by which we could continue to scale the project to more and more and more contributors. Once a lot of that was in place and there were like a lot of like kind of new leaders established, I've been able to pull away from that quite a bit more. And so a lot of what I've been doing lately is working with the kind of team internally and externally to come up with a really consistent message and understanding of what Node is and why it's really successful. I think that the traditional view of Node.js is that it's this thing to write servers in. But if you look at our actual usage and our actual growth, we're so much more than that. I mean, the way that people develop front-end applications is now totally different, right?
制定实践和流程，通过这些实践和流程，我们可以继续将项目扩展到越来越多的贡献者。一旦大部分工作到位，并且建立了很多新的领导者，我就能够更多地从这些事务中抽身出来。所以我最近做的很多事情是与内部和外部的团队合作，以形成一个非常一致的信息，并理解 Node 是什么以及为什么它如此成功。我认为 Node.js 的传统观点是，它是一个用来编写服务器的东西。但如果你看看我们的实际使用情况和实际增长，我们远不止于此。我的意思是，人们开发前端应用程序的方式现在完全不同了，对吧？
Like, nobody used compiler chains unless you worked on Dojo, like, seven years ago. And now everybody doing modern open-source development is using a compile chain written in Node.js. I mean, now, like, the new front-end framework is not a thing that you stick in a script tag. It's a thing that you use in a compile chain written in Node.js, like React, right?
就像，七年前，除非你在做 Dojo，否则没人使用编译器链。而现在，每个进行现代开源开发的人都在使用用 Node.js 编写的编译器链。我的意思是，现在，新的前端框架不再是你贴在 script 标签里的东西。它是你在用 Node.js 编写的编译器链中使用的东西，比如 React，对吧？
And so, right. So front-end development has totally changed. You also have Electron being used by a huge amount of desktop applications now. I cannot believe that a desktop framework took off this quickly. And is now, you know, like Node is now the easiest way to build cross-platform desktop applications. Yeah. For people who don't know, we covered Electron in our tool
所以，对。所以前端开发已经完全改变了。你现在还有 Electron 被大量的桌面应用程序使用。我无法相信一个桌面框架能如此迅速地流行起来。而且现在，你知道，Node 现在是构建跨平台桌面应用程序的最简单方法。是的。对于那些不知道的人，我们在我们的工具
of the show. But actually, we covered native of fire in our tool of the show, which uses Electron. And that was a tool where you could just say, you know, google.com, and it makes a, like an app, like a OS 10 app for Google, like you could have the Google app, and it has an icon here, just some things like that. And so electron is a way to wrap a website into an application. And I didn't even know that was written in Node.js. But it makes sense when you think about it. Yep, it's I mean, it's not in WebKit. But I think a lot of the power there is coming from you know using web technologies to create the whole front-end experience but then having node um to handle networking and file system and a lot of other stuff um so i mean a lot of people don't
节目中介绍了 Electron。但实际上，我们在工具节目中介绍了 native of fire，它使用了 Electron。那是一个工具，你可以直接说，你知道，google.com，它就会为 Google 制作一个应用程序，就像 OS 10 应用程序一样，就像你可以拥有 Google 应用程序，它这里有一个图标，诸如此类。所以 Electron 是一种将网站包装成应用程序的方法。我甚至不知道它是用 Node.js 编写的。但当你想到它时，这就说得通了。是的，我的意思是，它不在 WebKit 中。但我认为那里的很多力量来自于，你知道，使用 Web 技术来创建整个前端体验，然后拥有 Node 来处理网络、文件系统和其他很多东西，所以我的意思是，很多人没有
realize but the slack desktop application is written in electron the um microsoft's visual studio code editor is written in Electron using Node.js. Yeah, yeah. It feels native, and so people aren't really recognizing when this kind of stuff happens. Kind of the way that a lot of apps that you use on your phone you think of as iOS apps are actually written in Cordova using web technologies, also using Node.js actually now as well. Yeah, yeah. And that that's a big part of node um cordova is a big part of node doing you know mobile and tablet applications um also
意识到，但 Slack 桌面应用程序是用 Electron 编写的，微软的 Visual Studio Code 编辑器是用 Electron 使用 Node.js 编写的。是的，是的。它感觉很原生，所以人们并没有真正意识到这种事情发生时的情况。就像你在手机上使用的许多应用程序，你认为它们是 iOS 应用程序，实际上是用 Cordova 使用 Web 技术编写的，现在实际上也都在使用 Node.js。是的，是的。那也是 Node 的很大一部分，Cordova 是 Node 进行移动和平板应用程序开发的重要组成部分，还有
iot is really taking off so um last year all of the new iot embedded platforms now run node on device right so even low power um so that's just been like a tremendous shift. And then also, all the new cloud technologies, the serverless technologies like Lambda and Google Cloud Functions and Azure Functions, they're all on Node as well. And sometimes Node is the only platform that they're supporting right now. Yeah, yeah. And then, you know, Node is huge in enterprise now as well. The microservice stacks, 90% of what people are running on top of all that stack is just Node.
物联网（IoT）确实正在腾飞，所以去年所有新的物联网嵌入式平台现在都在设备上运行 Node，对吧？即使是低功耗的，所以这确实是一个巨大的转变。而且，所有新的云技术，像 Lambda、Google Cloud Functions 和 Azure Functions 这样的无服务器技术，它们也都运行在 Node 上。有时 Node 是它们目前唯一支持的平台。是的，是的。而且，你知道，Node 现在在企业中也非常庞大。微服务堆栈，人们在所有这些堆栈之上运行的东西中，90% 只是 Node。
So when we started looking and really breaking down why is Node so successful in all these areas, where is the growth coming from, it's really kind of self-reinforcing. We talk a lot about Polyglot and a lot about the best tool for the job. And I think that if you're a really experienced developer, that's an amazing luxury to just be able to run anything
所以当我们开始审视并真正分析为什么 Node 在所有这些领域都如此成功，增长来自哪里时，它实际上是一种自我强化。我们谈论了很多关于多语言（Polyglot）和针对工作选择最佳工具的问题。我认为，如果你是一个非常有经验的开发人员，能够运行任何东西
and be able to select a language. But the vast majority of developers just want to get a thing done. Like learning a language is another thing in the way of them getting something done. And Node being this much more transferable, universal skill set across IoT and back-end and front-end, it really kind of lowers the barrier to entry to building these bigger, complex applications and this really, really big new full stack that you have to contend with.
并能够选择一种语言，那是一种了不起的奢侈。但绝大多数开发人员只是想把事情做完。学习一门语言是阻碍他们完成某件事的另一件事。而 Node 这种在物联网、后端和前端之间更具可移植性、更通用的技能组合，确实降低了构建这些更大、更复杂的应用程序以及你必须应对的这个非常非常庞大的新全栈的门槛。
And having a unified debugging environment and a unified tool chain for when you're working on an IoT device or on a front-end application is really huge. That makes sense. So a couple of things. One is, these are kind of more kind of nits, I guess, about Node that I'm curious. One is, I know ES6 has its own type of, I guess, require. And so will Node kind of adopt that? Because one kind of issue that I think Browserify was able to do pretty well, there's also RequireJS and some of these other ones, was that when you wrote something in Node,
并且拥有一个统一的调试环境和一个统一的工具链，当你在物联网设备或前端应用程序上工作时，这真的很重要。这说得通。所以有几件事。一个是，这些是关于 Node 的一些更细微的问题，我很好奇。一个是，我知道 ES6 有它自己类型的，我想是 require。那么 Node 会采用它吗？因为我认为 Browserify 能够做得很好的一点，还有 RequireJS 和其他一些，就是当你用 Node 编写某些东西时，
that code didn't just also work on the browser. Like if you had something like a combinatorics library where you had to do it in Node, but then you also needed something on the browser. But you had to do all this crazy stuff to wrap the code so that it could run on both. And are you sort of working with the browser JavaScript community to try to make cross-client server development easier? Well, I think, you know, the ecosystem is really figuring this out for us. I mean, I think that, you know, when Node started,
那段代码不仅仅在浏览器上也能工作。就像如果你有一个组合数学库，你必须在 Node 中完成它，但随后你还需要在浏览器上使用某些东西。但你必须做所有这些疯狂的事情来包装代码，以便它可以在两者上运行。你们是否正在与浏览器 JavaScript 社区合作，试图让跨客户端服务器开发变得更容易？嗯，我认为，你知道，生态系统确实在为我们解决这个问题。我的意思是，我认为，你知道，当 Node 开始时，
a lot of the problem was that the majority of JavaScript that anybody had ever seen was written for the browser and relied on some DOM APIs that we didn't have in Node, right? So Node was like this new kind of virgin platform and didn't have any modules on it. Now Node has more reusable modules than anywhere else, right? And so there's this huge amount of incentive for people to come up with tool chains
很多问题在于，任何人见过的绝大多数 JavaScript 都是为浏览器编写的，并且依赖于一些我们在 Node 中没有的 DOM API，对吧？所以 Node 就像这种新的处女地平台，上面没有任何模块。现在 Node 拥有比任何地方都多的可重用模块，对吧？所以人们有巨大的动力去想出工具链，
that make all that work in the browser in a variety of contexts. As far as ES6 modules go, that's sort of like a much more complicated question than I wish it was. I think that today, a lot of people are already using ES6 modules just through a compiler chain, especially if you're doing front-end stuff.
使所有这些在各种环境下的浏览器中都能工作。至于 ES6 模块，这是一个比我希望的要复杂得多的问题。我认为今天，很多人已经通过编译器链在使用 ES6 模块了，特别是如果你在做前端工作的话。
But even some people doing back-end stuff are just using a compiler chain because they like ES6 modules. And there's not a huge amount of value that gets added to that experience by having it work natively. And I think also a lot of people are still going to rely on those compiler chains if they've opted into them today, because there's going to be new features that still aren't in V8 yet that are like the next feature that people want to play with. Right. Um, I think a lot of people that, you know, want to see a lot of this stuff come in natively, they're also using a weight, so they're not going to dump that compiler chain anytime soon.
但即使是一些做后端工作的人也只是在使用编译器链，因为他们喜欢 ES6 模块。而且通过原生支持它，并不会给那种体验增加太大的价值。而且我认为很多人如果今天已经选择了这些编译器链，他们仍然会依赖它们，因为会有新的功能，而这些功能在 V8 中还没有，它们是人们想要尝试的下一个功能。对。嗯，我认为很多人，你知道，希望看到很多这些东西原生进入，他们也在使用 await，所以他们不会很快放弃那个编译器链。
Right. Or they're using async await and other features that aren't in V8 yet. And we don't even know when they will land in V8. Can you explain to the audience out there, like, what's a compiler chain mean in this context? Right, a compiler chain is just something that takes your code and then turns it into other code that will run and execute in different
对。或者他们正在使用 async await 和其他 V8 中还没有的功能。我们甚至不知道它们何时会进入 V8。你能向外面的观众解释一下，在这个上下文中编译器链意味着什么吗？对，编译器链只是获取你的代码，然后将其转换为将在不同
environments, right? So if you wanted to run in the browser environment, you would run it through the compiler chain that makes it work, you know, with the browser and not relying on a bunch of node APIs and adding, you know, intermediate modules or polyfills or whatever needs to happen to make those work. Gotcha. Right, right.
环境中运行和执行的其他代码的东西，对吧？所以如果你想在浏览器环境中运行，你会通过编译器链运行它，使其能够工作，你知道，与浏览器兼容，而不依赖于一堆 Node API，并添加，你知道，中间模块或 polyfill 或任何需要发生的事情来使它们工作。明白了。对，对。
And yeah, yeah. And so there is a discussion right now about how to get ES6 modules into Node. And it's a much more complicated discussion than anybody had ever thought because there were some assumptions made about detection of what module type that you're in. That's handled by the browser by a difference in the script tag that we don't have.
是的，是的。所以现在有一个关于如何将 ES6 模块引入 Node 的讨论。这是一个比任何人想象的都要复杂得多的讨论，因为在检测你处于哪种模块类型方面做出了一些假设。这在浏览器中是通过 script 标签的差异来处理的，而我们没有这个。
And so the way that we detect that and turn it on is up for a very contentious debate right now. So I unfortunately don't have a great answer. Gotcha. So one other sort of... Before we start, keep spiraling down this, I want to go back to something you were saying before, which was,
所以我们如何检测它并开启它，目前正处于一场非常激烈的辩论中。所以我很遗憾没有一个好的答案。明白了。所以还有一件事……在我们开始继续深入探讨之前，我想回到你之前说的一些事情，那就是，
so, you know, people start a new project, there's this right tool for the right job, and, you know, that's part of what the podcast kind of sets out to do is talk about
所以，你知道，人们开始一个新项目，有这种针对工作的正确工具，而且，你知道，这也是播客旨在做的事情的一部分，就是谈论
all these different tools so people know all the options out there. But in most big companies, you don't really get that luxury. I mean, it would be nice, but, you know, you kind of are limited to
所有这些不同的工具，这样人们就知道所有的选择。但在大多数大公司，你并没有那种奢侈。我的意思是，那会很好，但是，你知道，你有点局限于
C++, Java, maybe Python. If you're doing web stuff, there's JavaScript and stuff. But as somebody who is starting out or trying to transition into programming, Node.js has enabled people to, as you said, do more than just front-end website scripting
C++、Java，也许是 Python。如果你在做 Web 开发，有 JavaScript 之类的。但作为一个刚起步或试图转型进入编程领域的人，Node.js 已经使人们能够，正如你所说，做不仅仅是前端网站脚本
in JavaScript. Do you think that Node.js, JavaScript combined, has the ability to kind of be one of those core things that if you learn this as a first language, it has the legs to take you far into your career? Do you think it's there already? It will be there? What are your views on that aspect of Node?
的 JavaScript 开发。你认为 Node.js 和 JavaScript 结合在一起，是否有能力成为那种核心事物，如果你把它作为第一语言学习，它有足够的潜力让你在职业生涯中走得很远吗？你认为它已经达到了吗？它会达到吗？你对 Node 的那个方面有什么看法？
I do think that it's there today. I mean, especially over the last year with the changes that have happened in IoT. I mean, Node is now supported on device probably more than any other language on IoT platforms. And that was kind of the last space that we were worried about being a fit for, right? It's hard to run on embedded hardware,
我确实认为它今天已经达到了。我的意思是，特别是在过去一年中，随着物联网领域发生的变化。我的意思是，Node 现在在物联网平台上的设备支持可能比任何其他语言都要多。而那正是我们担心是否适合的最后一个领域，对吧？在嵌入式硬件上运行很难，
but it's happened. And a lot of the work that we've done being very, very efficient has really paid off there. I think, you know, to come back to some of the points that you made earlier, I think that I don't want to say that, you know, Node being a more universal language and people doing more kind of full stack stuff with Node is actually at odds with this notion of polyglot, because they're not entirely, right? So if you look at what's happening in enterprises, they're adopting more or less like these microservice stacks, right?
但它已经发生了。而且我们所做的非常非常高效的很多工作在那里确实得到了回报。我想，你知道，回到你之前提出的一些观点，我认为我不想说，你知道，Node 成为一种更通用的语言，人们用 Node 做更多全栈的东西，实际上与这种多语言的概念相矛盾，因为它们并不完全矛盾，对吧？所以如果你看看企业中正在发生的事情，他们或多或少地采用了这些微服务堆栈，对吧？
So they have Cloud Foundry, Kubernetes, Docker, whatever. But they basically have a way to build out infrastructure and then run anything on top of it. So they're not going to get vendor locked in the way that they did the last time that they did a big technology run 10 years ago, right? They want to be on top of it. So they're not going to get vendor locked in the way that they did the last time that they did a big technology run 10 years ago, right? Like they want to be on top of all these standards so that they can move providers and so that they can run anything. So the barriers to running a Go process in production, even though you've never run a Go process in production, is getting lower, even in enterprises, right? And that's a really good
所以他们有 Cloud Foundry、Kubernetes、Docker 等等。但他们基本上有一种方法来构建基础设施，然后在上面运行任何东西。所以他们不会像 10 年前进行上一次大型技术转型时那样被供应商锁定，对吧？他们想站在顶端。所以他们不会像 10 年前进行上一次大型技术转型时那样被供应商锁定，对吧？就像他们想站在所有这些标准的顶端，以便他们可以更换提供商，并且他们可以运行任何东西。所以即使你从未在生产环境中运行过 Go 进程，在生产环境中运行 Go 进程的障碍也在降低，即使在企业中也是如此，对吧？而那是一个非常好的
thing because if somebody writes a really good analytics tool or a really good database in Go, they should be able to run that in their infrastructure without a huge barrier in the way. But the flip side of this is that deadlines are getting shorter. People have to do more with less. The communication overhead between having a team that only works on backend stuff and only works on frontend stuff is a really big barrier to getting things done. And so what we're seeing kind of across the industry, even in enterprises, is that Node allows people to reduce the number of people that are on these teams, have the back-end people and the front-end people working much more together. Even when you have a person that only works on front-end and only works on back-end, having them in the same team and speaking the same language is really, really useful.
事情，因为如果有人用 Go 编写了一个非常好的分析工具或一个非常好的数据库，他们应该能够在他们的基础设施中运行它，而不会有巨大的障碍。但这一点的另一面是，截止日期越来越短。人们必须用更少的资源做更多的事情。拥有一个只负责后端工作和只负责前端工作的团队之间的沟通开销，是完成工作的一个非常大的障碍。所以我们看到在整个行业中，即使在企业中，Node 也允许人们减少这些团队中的人数，让后端人员和前端人员更多地协同工作。即使你有一个只负责前端和只负责后端的人，让他们在同一个团队中并说同一种语言也是非常有用的。
And you have a lot more mobility and agency between people because they can do more inside of the organization and aren't limited by, you know, the language or the platform that they're used to. So tearing down these barriers is just like a really good thing. And one of the reasons why we're seeing such tremendous adoption is because we do such a great job of tearing down those barriers. I don't think that means that we'll stop seeing other languages and seeing people use other languages that are great at particular things. But when I look at what those companies might look like in the future, I really do think that Node is going to be the majority of what they run. But that last slice of what else they're doing is going to be a ton of different languages that
而且你在人员之间有更多的流动性和代理权，因为他们可以在组织内部做更多的事情，而不受他们习惯的语言或平台的限制。所以打破这些障碍是一件非常好的事情。我们看到如此巨大的采用率的原因之一，是因为我们在打破这些障碍方面做得非常好。我不认为这意味着我们将停止看到其他语言，或者看到人们使用在特定方面表现出色的其他语言。但当我展望这些公司在未来可能的样子时，我确实认为 Node 将占据他们运行的大部分。但他们正在做的其他事情的最后一部分将是大量的不同语言，这些语言
are amazing at very particular things. Is there a couple things you could give to say, if you're looking at Node to do this, you should look elsewhere? Since you just said it runs in most, I won't force you to say the things that mean you should use it, but let's ask the more interesting question of, hey, if my project involves,
在非常特定的方面非常出色。有没有什么你可以给出的建议，说如果你正在考虑用 Node 做这个，你应该去别处看看？既然你刚才说它在大多数地方都能运行，我就不强迫你说那些意味着你应该使用它的事情了，但让我们问一个更有趣的问题，嘿，如果我的项目涉及，
like you said before, I spent a long portion of my life doing embedded hardware, so I would never have turned to JavaScript before. I do agree I see it coming out more. I don't know that I would still turn to it yet, but that's my personal opinion. But what are the things that are still out of bounds or not probably a good choice for implementing in Node? Okay, well, I do want to respond a little bit to what you said, though, about you using it, right? Like, one of the great things about Node running on these devices isn't that, you know,
就像你之前说的，我花了我生命中很大一部分时间做嵌入式硬件，所以我以前绝不会转向 JavaScript。我确实同意我看到它越来越多地出现。我不知道我是否还会转向它，但那是我的个人观点。但还有哪些东西仍然是超出范围的，或者可能不是在 Node 中实现的最佳选择？好吧，我确实想对你刚才说的关于你使用它的事情做一点回应，对吧？就像，Node 在这些设备上运行的伟大之处不在于，你知道，
it makes things a little bit different for people that were already able to write for those devices, is that it opens it up, like those devices up to so many more people that can now develop on it, because it's using Node.js and it's making things so much simpler, right? So it's really just reducing the barrier to entry to getting into those devices. In terms of what is Node bad at, I get this question all the time, and it's really hard to answer because in the early days of Node, the things that we said you shouldn't do with Node ended up being the largest growth areas for Node. So what do you want your next big growth area to be? you shouldn't do with Node ended up being the largest growth areas for Node. So what do you want your next big growth area to be?
它为那些已经能够为这些设备编写程序的人带来了一些不同，而在于它向更多的人开放了这些设备，他们现在可以在上面开发，因为它使用 Node.js，而且它让事情变得简单多了，对吧？所以它真的只是降低了进入这些设备的门槛。至于 Node 不擅长什么，我一直被问到这个问题，而且真的很难回答，因为在 Node 的早期，我们说你不应该用 Node 做的事情，最终成为了 Node 最大的增长领域。所以你希望你的下一个大增长领域是什么？
There was actually a panel of all of the early Node core people at NodeConf, my first NodeConf actually that I ran in 2010, and sort of asked them, like, hey, what should you not do with Node? And they said, you know, anything that's like a bash script
实际上，在 NodeConf 上有一个所有早期 Node 核心人员的小组讨论，那是我在 2010 年举办的第一次 NodeConf，我问他们，嘿，你不应该用 Node 做什么？他们说，你知道，任何像 bash 脚本
and writing compiler and tools like that, don't use code right so that's one of the biggest growth areas that we have is in front end tools like that people used to do and things like bash and the other was databases uh and we actually have a huge amazing thriving uh bespoke database community uh built on top of the level db um those are both amazing areas of work for Node. So yeah, I think the one thing that if I look at other languages and I'm going to get jealous about, and every language does something amazing, right? They all have something they can learn from.
和编写编译器和类似工具的东西，不要使用代码，对吧？所以这是我们拥有的最大增长领域之一，是在像人们过去常做的那样的前端工具中，以及像 bash 中的东西，另一个是数据库，呃，我们实际上有一个庞大、令人惊叹、蓬勃发展的定制数据库社区，建立在 level db 之上，这两个都是 Node 非常棒的工作领域。所以是的，我认为如果我看看其他语言，我会感到嫉妒，而且每种语言都做了一些令人惊叹的事情，对吧？它们都有值得学习的地方。
You haven't seen Whitespace. Yeah, you should check out our Whitespace language episode. Right, right. Most, you should check out our Whitespace language episode. Right, right. Most, I will say. If I'm looking around, though, and I actually get jealous of something, the fact that Go doesn't bind to LibC and that they went so far in the direction of everything just comes into this platform,
你还没见过 Whitespace。是的，你应该看看我们的 Whitespace 语言那一集。对，对。大多数，你应该看看我们的 Whitespace 语言那一集。对，对。大多数，我会说。如果我环顾四周，但我确实对某件事感到嫉妒，那就是 Go 不绑定到 LibC，而且他们在一切都进入这个平台的方向上走得太远了，
it's given them some really interesting portability that you have of the actual final compilation, which is really cool. And also, Libsyn's kind of garbage, so that's nice. And also, I think that they also have a custom crypto implementation, which is in Go. And this is one of the things that people don't get about, um, building out ecosystems and languages is that in the early days, people
这给了他们一些非常有趣的可移植性，你拥有实际的最终编译，这真的很酷。而且 Libsyn 也很垃圾，所以这很好。而且我认为他们还有一个自定义的加密实现，是用 Go 编写的。这是人们在构建生态系统和语言时没有理解的事情之一，那就是在早期，人们
will show up to build anything that you don't have. Um, and so it's actually, you know, like bootstrapping, like every, every JVM language does this thing, right. Where they go like, no, no, it's great. You can use all of the Java stuff, uh, and you don't have to switch over. And that's actually like not a great way to build an ecosystem because people don't show up to build like that thing in that language. And when Node started out, we were so incompatible with the whole world. So like you couldn't bind to any of the C libraries that everybody binds to because they all use blocking IO, right? So we had to write our own MySQL driver, our own Postgres driver. And we also weren't compatible
会出现构建任何你没有的东西。嗯，所以它实际上，你知道，就像引导程序，就像每种 JVM 语言都做这种事情，对吧。他们说，不，不，这很棒。你可以使用所有的 Java 东西，呃，你不需要切换过来。而这实际上并不是构建生态系统的好方法，因为人们不会出现去用那种语言构建那种东西。当 Node 开始时，我们与整个世界是如此不兼容。所以你不能绑定到每个人都绑定的任何 C 库，因为它们都使用阻塞 IO，对吧？所以我们必须编写我们自己的 MySQL 驱动程序，我们自己的 Postgres 驱动程序。而且我们也不兼容
with any of the JavaScript on the web because we didn't have a DOM. That actually ended up being one of the secrets to our success was that so many people showed up and wrote these native implementations of everything. And Go has done that even a little bit more with their crypto stuff.
与 Web 上的任何 JavaScript，因为我们没有 DOM。这实际上最终成为了我们成功的秘诀之一，因为有那么多人出现并编写了所有这些东西的原生实现。而 Go 在他们的加密东西上做得甚至更多一点。
They also pay a guy at Google to write that. But yeah, I think that that's really cool. That's something really cool that they were able to do. And I don't think anytime in the future, we're going to have a pure JavaScript crypto implementation. So if I think about like, if I was thinking of like strengths and drawbacks, I I tell everyone the first thing you should learn is JavaScript you can build a cool website, you can do the backend in Node but I would say the biggest drawback for me for Node would be the weak typing
他们还付钱给谷歌的一个人来写那个。但是是的，我认为这真的很酷。这是他们能够做到的非常酷的事情。而且我不认为在未来的任何时候，我们会有一个纯 JavaScript 的加密实现。所以如果我考虑，如果我在考虑优势和缺点，我会告诉每个人你应该学习的第一件事是 JavaScript，你可以构建一个很酷的网站，你可以在 Node 中做后端，但我会说 Node 对我来说最大的缺点是弱类型
and we constantly get feedback about what is strong typing what is weak typing, we look this up and it turns out weak and strong typing is whatever you want it to be so but basically the fact that you just say a equals three now a is a string versus you know Scala with type inferencing Swift with type inferencing Java with strong typing right and so I know there's there's something from Microsoft, like a TypeScript, that might work with Node. But other than that, what are sort of ways to get good type inferencing or strong typing? Is Node looking into that?
我们不断收到关于什么是强类型什么是弱类型的反馈，我们查了一下，结果发现强弱类型是你想要它是什么就是什么，所以基本上你只是说 a 等于 3，现在 a 是一个字符串，而不是，你知道，带有类型推断的 Scala，带有类型推断的 Swift，带有强类型的 Java，对吧？所以我知道有来自微软的东西，比如 TypeScript，它可能与 Node 一起工作。但除此之外，获得良好类型推断或强类型的方法有哪些？Node 在研究这个吗？
So this is an area of deep thought. So a lot of the performance benefits that you get out of typing, we actually have in JavaScript, right? Like if you really look at how the VM optimizations work is that they figure out the types and they create like these inline, they do this inlining or they do some tracing or something.
所以这是一个深思熟虑的领域。所以你从类型中获得的大部分性能优势，我们实际上在 JavaScript 中都有，对吧？如果你真的看看 VM 优化是如何工作的，它们会找出类型并创建像内联这样的东西，它们进行这种内联，或者它们进行一些跟踪之类的。
So JavaScript VMs have a lot of ways of making things as fast as if you were using the typing. So there's not really like a big, in my mind, a huge performance thing to be said about this. I think that if you want... There are a bunch of people, though, that really like the early errors and the early type errors
所以 JavaScript VM 有很多方法使事情变得像你使用类型时一样快。所以在我看来，关于这一点并没有什么巨大的性能可言。我认为如果你想要……不过，有一群人确实喜欢早期错误和早期类型错误
and a lot of the changes that it makes to the way in which you program. I don't actually agree, me personally. Like, I mean, I started out with Assembly and C, and I come from a background of lower-level languages. And at no time when I went from, you know, statically typed languages to dynamic languages did I go, oh, man, I really wish I had type errors again.
以及它对你的编程方式所做的很多改变。我实际上不同意，我个人。我的意思是，我从汇编和 C 开始，我来自低级语言的背景。当我从，你知道，静态类型语言转向动态语言时，我从来没有说，哦，天哪，我真的很希望再次拥有类型错误。
That's just not, like, something that I've ever said. And actually, I do find that there's something of a correlation between people that get really into type safety tend to be people that started with dynamic languages and then looked at type languages. And it's kind of the opposite as you might expect. Oh, really? Yeah, yeah. It's really fun to watch. So yeah, I'm not personally a huge fan about that. I will say, though, I heard, I was talking to, I think, Tom Dale about this a while back, and he was looking at moving some of the Ember code base over to TypeScript. And one of the reasons that he cited, which I think is actually pretty smart, is that because all of the JavaScript optimizations are based on typing,
那根本不是，你知道，我曾经说过的话。而且实际上，我确实发现那些非常热衷于类型安全的人与那些从动态语言开始然后查看类型语言的人之间存在某种相关性。这和你可能预期的正好相反。哦，真的吗？是的，是的。看着很有趣。所以是的，我个人并不是那种东西的忠实粉丝。不过，我会说，我听说，我前段时间和 Tom Dale 谈过这个，他正在考虑将一些 Ember 代码库迁移到 TypeScript。他引用的原因之一，我认为实际上非常聪明，是因为所有的 JavaScript 优化都是基于类型的，
and if you end up switching the types too much, you end up getting out of optimizations. Moving a code base that you even expect people to just use in JavaScript over to TypeScript means that you're always going to use the same types and you're always going to hit the fast paths. And so it's a nice way to make sure that without sitting down and by hand going through all your code and figuring out where the JS VM is de-optimizing, you just get all that for free. And so that was a really good argument, I think, for TypeScript.
如果你最终切换类型太多，你最终会失去优化。将一个你甚至期望人们只在 JavaScript 中使用的代码库迁移到 TypeScript 意味着你总是会使用相同的类型，并且你总是会命中快速路径。所以这是一种确保你不会坐下来手工检查所有代码并找出 JS VM 在哪里进行反优化，你只是免费获得所有这些的好方法。所以这对于 TypeScript 来说是一个很好的论点，我认为。
Oh, that makes sense. But you can totally use it with Node.js. I've never tried this, but I'm assuming you can go TypeScript to JavaScript and then do Node, your new JavaScript file, and you're good to go. Yeah, so the Visual Studio Code Editor is built in TypeScript. Oh, I see. Okay, and that runs on Node.
哦，那说得通。但你完全可以将它与 Node.js 一起使用。我从来没有尝试过这个，但我假设你可以从 TypeScript 到 JavaScript，然后做 Node，你的新 JavaScript 文件，你就准备好了。是的，所以 Visual Studio Code 编辑器是用 TypeScript 构建的。哦，我明白了。好的，它运行在 Node 上。
Yep. Very cool. Yeah. So we talk about how people can get started in open source projects, but also people new to programming are looking for a first project. You said there was some cool Internet of Things that will run Node. You talked about building, you talked about projects that can allow you to build Electron,
是的。非常酷。是的。所以我们谈论人们如何开始开源项目，但刚接触编程的人也在寻找第一个项目。你说有一些很酷的物联网可以运行 Node。你谈到了构建，你谈到了允许你构建 Electron 的项目，
to build desktop applications. Could you kind of give some recommendations as people who want to get a taste of Node or are new to programming in general and want to say, what is there something cool I could build? Like some examples at various pieces of the stack maybe where Node is used and what people could do or look at there to kind of get inspiration?
构建桌面应用程序。你能给一些建议吗，作为那些想尝尝 Node 的味道或者刚接触编程的人，想说，有什么很酷的东西我可以构建吗？比如在堆栈的各个部分可能使用 Node 的一些例子，以及人们可以做什么或看什么来获得灵感？
So I think that if you're just sitting down to try to learn, the best resource is NodeSchool. So you can go to nodeschool.io. There's a bunch of workshops there that are like choose your own adventure workshops where you, you know, learn by doing and it tests your code and all that kind of stuff. And, you know, you can learn anything from, you know, learning basic JavaScript, basic node, uh, to Johnny five, IOT stuff, uh, to, um, there's even one for web GL. If you want to, you know, use the sack GL components that runs in the browser and does like 3d model diffing and stuff.
所以我认为如果你只是坐下来尝试学习，最好的资源是 NodeSchool。所以你可以去 nodeschool.io。那里有一堆研讨会，就像选择你自己的冒险研讨会，你，你知道，通过做来学习，它测试你的代码等等。而且，你知道，你可以学习任何东西，从，你知道，学习基础 JavaScript，基础 Node，呃，到 Johnny five 物联网东西，呃，到，嗯，甚至有一个用于 web GL 的。如果你想，你知道，使用在浏览器中运行并进行 3d 模型差异之类的 sack GL 组件。
It's crazy. Um, yeah, yeah, no, it's, it's an incredible resource for, for learning stuff. Um, and there's also, um, a community on, on GitHub that will, you's an incredible resource for learning stuff. And there's also a community on GitHub that will help you get through anything. So if you get stuck, you can ask a question and people will help you get through it. So that's a tremendous resource that I point everybody to. In terms of, you know,
这太疯狂了。嗯，是的，是的，不，它是一个令人难以置信的学习资源。嗯，而且还有，嗯，GitHub 上的一个社区，它会，你是一个令人难以置信的学习资源。而且还有 GitHub 上的一个社区，它会帮助你度过任何难关。所以如果你卡住了，你可以问一个问题，人们会帮助你度过难关。所以这是一个我向每个人推荐的巨大资源。至于，你知道，
it really depends on what you want to build. I think that there are sub-communities around different parts of Node that you can get involved in. So if you're interested in robotics, there's an amazing community called NodeBots that does a lot of amazing robot stuff in IoT. There's a library called Johnny5 for doing IoT and hardware stuff that has a great community around it. It's actually built by one of the core contributors to jQuery, and so it has that kind of jQuery ease of use baked into it. So that's a really good resource. Obviously, the desktop application stuff, you should really look at Electron. I think the Cordova project is great if you're looking at mobile stuff.
这真的取决于你想构建什么。我认为围绕 Node 的不同部分有许多子社区，你可以参与其中。如果你对机器人技术感兴趣，有一个很棒的社区叫 NodeBots，他们在物联网领域做了很多了不起的机器人项目。有一个叫 Johnny5 的库专门用于物联网和硬件开发，它周围也有一个很棒的社区。它实际上是由 jQuery 的核心贡献者之一构建的，因此它融入了 jQuery 那种易用性。所以这是一个非常好的资源。显然，如果是桌面应用程序，你应该看看 Electron。如果你关注移动端，我认为 Cordova 项目很棒。
Let me think here. Who else has a great community that I'm forgetting? Oh, if you're interested in WebGL stuff, there's a community called StackGL, which is small modules that implement all of the kind of fundamental math stuff around doing WebGL. They're great. And yeah, that's all that I can think of off the top of my head. Well, that was pretty impressive, actually.
让我想想。还有谁有很棒的社区是我忘记提到的？哦，如果你对 WebGL 感兴趣，有一个叫 StackGL 的社区，它由一些小模块组成，实现了围绕 WebGL 开发的所有基础数学功能。他们很棒。是的，我目前能想到的就这些了。嗯，这确实令人印象深刻。
I don't know. You should be ashamed that you could only name 30 projects. So I know you mentioned that uh obviously like money money doesn't solve open source community problems it creates more of them but but let's say uh my i start a company and my whole company runs on node.js and uh um how do you sort of uh like what what what can enterprise customers or users of Node.js do to sort of to help the community? I just go to one of these events is one of the ways. Yeah, yeah. For certain. I mean, that's that's also just a really good first step as well as to go to one of the interactive events. These are like the bigger kind of industry events as well. So they'll be very comfortable there.
我不知道。你只能列举出 30 个项目，你应该感到羞愧。我知道你提到过，显然金钱并不能解决开源社区的问题，反而会制造更多问题。但假设我创办了一家公司，我的整个公司都运行在 Node.js 上，那么企业客户或 Node.js 用户可以做些什么来帮助社区呢？去参加这些活动是其中一种方式吗？是的，当然。我的意思是，参加互动活动确实是一个非常好的第一步。这些也是规模较大的行业活动。所以他们在那里会感到非常自在。
I think it really depends on your level of investment and the level of dependence that you have as a business on Node, right? So, I mean, the Node.js Foundation has corporate members and we have an open door to any other corporate members that want to show up and get involved at any level. And that's, you know, how we fund the foundation and kind of keep the lights on. But it also gets you embedded into the sort of background marketing and messaging and
我认为这确实取决于你的投入程度以及作为企业对 Node 的依赖程度，对吧？我的意思是，Node.js 基金会有企业成员，我们对任何想要加入并参与其中的企业成员都敞开大门。这就是我们资助基金会并维持运营的方式。但这也能让你深入参与到背景营销和信息传递中，
just the sustainability side of the project. So if you're heavily dependent on Node, that's a good place to invest. I think also, if you have the resources, and if you're highly dependent, having your people start working on node core, and potentially, you know, giving them more and more time, possibly even full time to be able to continue to work on core is, it's an investment that pays huge dividend, to be honest, a lot of, you know, a lot of the really big kind of node users have these people that, you know honest. A lot of the really big kind of Node users have these people that dedicate a lot of their time to NodeCore,
以及项目的可持续性方面。所以如果你非常依赖 Node，那是一个很好的投资领域。我认为，如果你有资源，而且依赖程度很高，让你的员工开始参与 Node 核心开发，并可能给他们越来越多甚至全职的时间来继续从事核心工作，老实说，这是一项回报巨大的投资。很多大型 Node 用户都有这样的人，他们投入了大量时间在 Node 核心上，
and they have an insight into how Node works and where things are going that have really helped those businesses. So, yeah, that's another really great way to get involved. And, you know, you can really get involved at every level. I mean, even the build infrastructure for building and testing Node. It's, you know, donated hardware and a bunch of open source contributors that manage, you know, this huge cluster and keep everything running. So, I mean, we're really, you know, we're there and have an open door for a lot of different types of skill sets. So you don't have to have a low-level C programmer to get involved in the Node project.
他们对 Node 的工作原理和未来发展方向有深入了解，这确实帮助了这些企业。所以，是的，这是另一种很好的参与方式。而且，你真的可以在各个层面参与进来。我的意思是，即使是用于构建和测试 Node 的构建基础设施，也是由捐赠的硬件和一群管理这个庞大集群并保持一切运行的开源贡献者组成的。所以，我们确实在那里，并为各种技能的人敞开大门。所以你不必非得是底层 C 程序员才能参与 Node 项目。
Well, I think we're approaching kind of the end here, but is there anything we haven't covered yet that you think people would be interested in hearing about? Anything you want to pitch? I think that we've covered pretty much all of our bases. I think that one of the things that we're doing as a foundation, and we're also working with the Linux Foundation on this, and I'm also putting in a lot of my kind of personal time, is trying to bring the public consciousness of open source up to where
好吧，我想我们快要结束了，但还有什么我们没涵盖到，你认为大家会感兴趣的吗？有什么你想推荐的吗？我认为我们已经涵盖了所有基本方面。我认为我们作为基金会正在做的一件事，也是与 Linux 基金会合作的，而且我也投入了大量个人时间，就是试图将公众对开源的认知提升到
open source actually is now. So we talked a little bit about how contributions are coming from people that are engaged a lot less, right? We have this, it's a, you know, not a long tail anymore. It's really like tail driven and the tail is the majority of the work. And the conversation around open source is always about kind of like these full-time open source people, a lot of ideas and argumentation about licensing and all of these things that really don't matter to modern open source developers. So we're really trying to push the consciousness of what an open source developer looks like just to the reality, not even trying to push it in any particular direction.
开源现在的实际水平。所以我们谈到了一些关于贡献来自那些参与度较低的人的情况，对吧？我们不再是长尾效应了。它更像是尾部驱动的，而尾部贡献了大部分工作。关于开源的讨论总是围绕着那些全职的开源人员，以及关于许可和所有这些对现代开源开发者来说并不重要的事情的各种想法和争论。所以我们真的在努力将开源开发者形象的认知推向现实，甚至不是试图将其推向任何特定方向。
Yeah, that totally makes sense. I know that I've contributed to various projects, and one of them I contributed to recently was Gradle. And they made me sign this whole thing and fax it to them. Like, I didn't even have a fax machine. I had to go hunting around for a fax machine. And it was just on their side, they're worried about me coming and saying, you know, look, I wrote this 30 line file in Gradle and now I own the project or something. And so I think, yeah, the legal area is one that has kind of fallen behind the way the ecosystem is now.
是的，这完全说得通。我知道我曾为各种项目做出过贡献，最近我贡献的一个项目是 Gradle。他们让我签署了所有这些文件并传真给他们。我甚至都没有传真机。我不得不四处寻找传真机。在他们那边，他们担心我会跑过来说，看，我写了这个 30 行的文件，现在我拥有这个项目了之类的。所以我认为，法律领域确实已经落后于当前的生态系统现状了。
Right, right. Well, and I mean, I've, you know, I've heard those lawyers say things to me as well. But the reality is that, like, one of the reasons why we have a foundation is because we have real lawyers that can tell us, like, the real risk profile here. And we also, you know, have IBM and Microsoft and these huge companies that also have lawyers that are interested in this. And so we end up with policies that everybody can agree to. But the opportunity cost of not getting a contribution because you have something like that is hard to quantify when the view of open source is that it's people that will jump through all these hoops that are highly motivated. And the reality is that actually we need to start
对，对。我的意思是，我也听过那些律师对我这么说。但现实是，我们拥有基金会的原因之一是因为我们有真正的律师可以告诉我们这里的真实风险状况。而且我们还有 IBM、微软这些大公司，他们也有关注此事的律师。因此，我们最终达成了每个人都能同意的政策。但是，因为有这样的障碍而失去贡献的机会成本，在开源被视为只有那些愿意跳过所有这些障碍且高度积极的人才会参与的视角下，是很难量化的。现实情况是，我们实际上需要开始
changing open source processes and policies and barriers to entry to accommodate a much more casual contribution base. So yeah, makes sense. Yeah. Awesome. Awesome. Yeah, it's great talking to you. Yeah, thank you so much. This interview is amazing. I think it really resonates with people. I mean, I personally, up until recently, I thought open source, various open source projects like Node.js, I would imagine it's five people in their basements around the world and just kind of hacking away at stuff. And it seems kind of very distant. The users and the contributors seem to
改变开源流程、政策和准入门槛，以适应更随意的贡献基础。所以，是的，说得通。太棒了。太棒了。和你聊天真好。是的，非常感谢。这次采访太棒了。我认为它真的引起了人们的共鸣。我的意思是，我个人直到最近还认为开源，像 Node.js 这样的各种开源项目，我想象中是五个人在世界各地的地下室里敲代码。这看起来很遥远。用户和贡献者似乎
be just two completely different communities and what you see especially now is all of that kind of coming together and community managers like you helping to sort of organize that and sort of push that philosophical shift so it's very cool and thank you
是两个完全不同的社区，而你现在看到的，特别是现在，是所有这些正在融合在一起，像你这样的社区经理帮助组织这一切，并推动这种哲学转变，所以这非常酷，谢谢你
for coming on the show no problem, anytime philosophical shift. So it's very cool. And thank you for coming on the show. No problem. Anytime. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来参加节目。没问题，随时欢迎。哲学转变。所以这非常酷。谢谢你来参加节目。没问题。随时欢迎。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。